الاسرائيليين وتلك
الحقيقه
التي لا تعزب في بعض الاحيان بعض الزملاء
الاسرائيليين اذا منذ اكثر من اربعه اشهر
غزه هي تحت القصف و حصار كامل وهم محرومين
بادنى المساعدات
لمعالجه المرضى والمصابين وكذلك مهددون
بالاوبئه ولا يمكنهم مغ
منطقه غزه وهم مدسون على الحدود في رفح
وليس هنالك اي مبرر لما يحصل ونطالب كذلك
الاحترام القانون الدولي الانساني وبوقف
دائم لاطلاق النار وادخال المستعدات
الانسانيه يجب وقف معاناه المدنيين وكذلك
يجب تحرير المحتجزين والرهائن
من داخل غزه وعلينا ان نعمل على
تحريرهم علينا
كذلك
نتجنب
تصعيد هذا النزاع وتوسعه في المنطقه وتجنب
الاستفزازات التي
ربما قد توصل الى ما لا تحمد عقبه خاصه في
الفه
الغربيه
الوطنين وذلك يزيد في الحقد والكراهيه ضد
الفلسطينيين هذه التصريحات من قبل
المسؤولين السياسيين التي تؤجج الوضع ضد
الفلسطينيين كذلك نذكر مثلما قام بذلك
زملاؤنا
الاردنيين انه لا يمكن ان يكون هنالك اي
تهجير قصري
للفلسطينيين لا خارج الضفه الغربيه ولا
خارج
غزه كذلك علينا ان
نبني
مستقل الاراضي المحتله
بالتنسيق مع السلطه الفلسطينيه نذكر بان
غزه هي ارض
فلسطينيه كل ذلك سيكون ممكنا فقط اذا ما
تم الوصول الى حل
حل الدولتين تتعايش جنب بعضهما
البعض
وهو امر عاجل ولن يكون هنالك سلام
واستقرار دائم بدون حل
الدولتين المعايير معروفه هي دوله
للفلسطينيين واعتراف متبادل لضمان كذلك
الامن لاسرائيل
ا لذلك السلطه الفلسطينيه تحتاج الى
المسانده وان تحترم اسرائيل هذا الوضع
الجديد و كذلك ان تحترم حقوقهم
السياسيه التصعيد في المنطقه في لبنان وفي
العراق وفي سوريا امر مثير
للقلق
وكذلك
سنعمل بدون تواني
لتجنب
تفشي هذا التصعيد خارج منطقه غزه ونحن
لدينا علاقات انسانيه وتاريخيه مع لبنان
تجعلنا نحث على امن ووحده اراضي لبنان مثل
ما نحرص على سلامه وحده اراضي
اسرائيل
واي خيار اخر سيزيد تاجيج الوضع في
المنطقه اذا ايها السيدات
والساده بعد فضاع السابع اكتوبر ليس هنالك
اي تبرير للارهاب ولا احد من اصدقاء
اسرائيل يتصور فض النزاع بدون حل الدوله
الفلسطينيه
وفرنسا عازمه على ان يصبح هذا واقعا
ومستداماً